approached away
I'm feeling free and I got today
hello everyone good evening
we are getting started
um we have some additional seats over
here if some people would like a seat
for this evening and not the stand I
recommend coming up over here we have
three seats over here
we have one over here we have
at least one or two up here
or you can stand let's get two
um hello my name is Andrew I'm one of
The Producers here at the long now
Foundation
um before we get started we're gonna do
a little bit of housekeeping
um please remember to silence your cell
phones
um
there's some standing area over here we
ask this meme more of the standing room
so that we can keep the exits clear over
by the Ori
um and tonight's program is going to be
a little bit longer than we usually do
so um we just encourage you to take care
of yourself if you need to go to the
bathroom or grab a drink or something
feel free to you're not being disruptive
don't worry
um that's it
so we all learned in kindergarten that
sharing is a virtue one of those things
that's essential for playing together
well
yeah as we get older we're told to
orient Our Lives towards Personal
Achievement Career Development and
accumulating property often at the
expense of sharing what would it take to
deprogram this persuasive culture norm
and take radical sharing seriously
what would it take for you to willingly
give up something you love something
that's part of your identity or you
worked hard for
joining us to explore these questions
this evening is beta adriance and
Chelsea T Hicks
[Applause]
Bata is a Dutch artist and novelist who
came to us VR board member Brian Eno and
as the Visionary behind all the
programming for tonight
Chelsea T Hicks is an indigenous
activist artist musician and poet
before we get to the rest of the evening
we're going to start with a performance
art video exploring the idea of
radically taking over public space note
this video is meant to be sonically
disruptive
enjoy
[Music]
for a long time
strategy and
it's about the reason between public and
private
serious
five six
five
years
is
around them
each other
has politely
[Music]
Human animals
to decide that space
to be nice you have to be a new
not that it's it is
[Music]
this was a video by Emily
she's a Danish upcoming artist and in
this video
she explores what it means when you
break the unspoken rules in our shared
property a public space what I also
really like about it is that it shows
what happens when you interrupt the
status quo when you raise your voice and
become a nuisance sometimes your voice
is drown out by the noise sometimes
you're shrill and annoying sometimes
people stare at you
welcome everyone
um thank you so much to the long now and
the interval for hosting us and thank
you all for being here and joining in
this discussion
tonight we'll be talking about property
and sharing
more specifically we'll be talking about
the question what can individuals and
communities do in order to change the
trajectory of increasing inequality in
the long term
welcome
don't worry I'm happy you're here
um I'll be talking with Chelsea Hicks uh
my guest and fellow author will join me
in a little bit and together we'll be
looking for answers and ideas and we
also have very exciting virtual guests
who are already taking action on this
topic in many ways as maybe a lot of you
are doing as well
um and they are going to share their
ideas and Thoughts with us
there's also a role for you this evening
we hope that you too will share your
ideas thoughts experiences knowledge
with us there's you found these two
things on your seat
on the back of this flyer you can take
some notes if you want
and this flyer has a question we hope
you'll be willing to answer this
question because this talk tonight will
lead up to an event at the internet
archive on Friday which is a workshop
where we will try to take this
conversation into action or take the
first steps towards action and your
ideas and thoughts and suggestions will
be the first steps
in that process
so before we get started I would like to
tell you a little bit about what got me
thinking about inequality
a few years back I started writing my
second novel called what's mine and it's
about a man named Louise
who lives in an apartment that he
inherited from his mother
when someone shows up who says Luis has
inherited this apartment in an unjust
way
from there the story escalates and it
escalates in ways that I didn't imagine
when I started writing the book
at the same time my personal life was
going through very big changes as well
when I started writing the book I was in
a white privileged middle class kind of
way poor I was in a huge debt by the
time I was halfway through the book
I was no longer in debt I was no longer
poor and my life had changed massively
everything got a lot better when I got
out of crushing debts uh for instance I
was able to I have time to make my art I
was able to quit my cleaning job I was
able to buy materials for my art I sold
a lot more I got jobs that suited my
skills better I was able to go to
important meetings in London and
Brussels and buy train tickets I was
even able to get a haircut for those
meetings
so while my life improved massively I
got stuck with a novel
because
I was writing about this guy who had to
ask himself am I really entitled to what
I have and how much can I share
and I wasn't ready to ask myself that
question I was so happy to get out of
trouble that I didn't want to think
about that about sharing
and all the research I was doing for the
book on inequality on sharing on
property rights suddenly made me very
feel really uneasy
well before these injustices just seemed
like something that someone else should
really be doing something about
and I thought
do I feel guilty about inequality
which seems like such a pointless
feeling to me
and then I realized it was
responsibility that I felt and not in
the sense that I felt responsible but in
the sense that I now had room in my life
to do something I now had the ability to
respond a responsibility
so I did
um I found out there are a lot of people
who felt like me that they had an unease
about where Society was and that they
had this urge to take action and the
question is
what can we do
I started together with Ann Fick and
Rodriguez who are both based here in the
Bay Area Network for scientists artists
people in media and businesses to work
together on social topics
the outcome so far has been really
incredible we've made a children's book
we've created a school program that we
implemented in schools together with
teachers and scientists and we very
often get together with people from all
kinds of fields to talk about how can we
effectively take action
so that's what we're doing here tonight
uh to see if we can find ways together
to take action
and I hope you will be willing to help
I was able to finish the book in The End
by the way it's here
um
before we before I asked Chelsea to join
me I just want to share a tiny bit of
the research that convinced me that this
topic is deserving of our attention
studies like the world's inequality
report from 2022 have shown that
inequality has been steadily On The Rise
since the 70s
inequalities within countries are now
even bigger than inequalities between
countries and in advanced countries like
the US inequality is increasing the
strongest
some percentages
um
one percent of the global population
holds 38 of global wealth and I'm aware
that you've heard these percentages
before
but I just want to repeat them 0.1
percent of the global population
holds 11 of global wealth while the
poorest half of the world
holds two percent of global wealth
the collective wealth of the
billionaires is increasing with 2
billion a 2.7 billion every day
so individuals individuals have gotten
richer governments have gotten poorer
and of course it's not just about wealth
inequality is also income resources
Education Health Care access to
Opportunities
um and our contribution to carbon
emissions all these inequalities are
increasing
and it affects everyone also the people
on the
more pleasant side of this equation are
affected because
it's shown many times that when
inequality increases
social cohesion lessons and crime Rises
so this is the science I'm not a
scientist I have a really hard time
remembering
um these statistics I've looked them up
many times I talked about many times and
they just won't stick
um I remember feelings so I remember
what it feels like when for instance
I stopped at a traffic light here in San
Francisco and I see a homeless mother
and her three children asking for help
and I drive on
I I know what it feels like when I see
somebody lying on the pavement and I
don't know if they're sleeping or passed
out or dead
and I know what it feels like and I
remember what it feels like when a
student gets into a prestigious master
program that could catapult their career
and then they don't have the money to
pay the fees
so maybe there's other things that you
remember maybe you remember faces or
anecdotes things that happen to you or
in your family maybe you are a real
statistics kind of person who looks at
the Hard numbers
um
I'm a story and oriented person
so I think about these things through
stories we can examine our feelings
through stories and we can
share our values through stories and we
can also hold on to our values through
stories and from our values
we make decisions
and from our decisions
we take action
the people I have invited are already
taking action they're doing things
I'm very grateful to everyone who is
doing things
because you'll be criticized you'll be
criticized for what you are doing and
you'll be criticized which for what you
aren't doing but we have to do things
we have to start taking action because
that point one percent who holds 11 of
global wealth is very actively doing
things right now
um my guess for tonight my co-host is
Chelsea T Hicks she's an Osage writer
and artist
she has
um she's one of the first authors to
publish her book in her ancestral
language of oshaji Iya
she has founded words of the people and
she's active in the land back movement
focusing on the concept of rematuration
which I'm sure she'll tell us something
about and I've gotten to know Chelsea
through her Story collection
a calm and normal heart in which she
introduces words from the wazasia
language
welcome Chelsea
[Applause]
Valley thank you but it's so good to be
here and thank you everybody for being
here
um so we're going to be talking about a
really big topic
um we're going to be talking about it by
asking three questions and the these
questions will build building onto each
other so
um the first question is
what is your own connection to the words
property and sharing so how do you
relate to those Concepts what part do
they play in your life
the next question is
how can we fix past injustices around
property or improve future ways of
sharing so where could our attention be
or where should our attention be
and then the final
big question
what can individuals and communities do
in order to change this trajectory of
increasing inequality in the long term
very big questions and we'll start with
the first one the smaller one
um Chelsea what is your connection to
the words property and sharing yeah so
when I think about property and sharing
I think about uh home ownership first
and I live in my ancestral lands the
outer edge of wajaje or Osage hunting
grounds which is in.cla dear tracks
Tulsi Tulsa Tulsa Oklahoma
and uh I want to own a home but I but I
don't and our reservation is nearby
about an hour north of Tulsa and I think
that uh owning a home there is a way to
signal to our community today that we're
invested in our people our language and
carrying on our ways however in 1906 uh
that land which we had purchased
collectively from the Cherokees when we
were being forced out of Kansas uh in
1906 that land was allotted and that
meant it was divided up into individual
plots of land which we didn't know how
to live that way and it was it was very
um impactful in a negative sense for our
community and we were also given oil
head rights at that time which that oil
ownership because we owned the we had
negotiated to own the minerals six
inches under the six feet under the
ground that had
um
resulted in us becoming wealthy from oil
and then subsequently attracting murders
and violence against our people so today
oil is enmesh in our identity and so I
think I have and all Native people today
may have like a complex relationship
with ownership because we can't live uh
communally as we used to you know it was
outlawed and and we were Ward upon for
for that concept so it holds a lot of
tension
I read that the and correct me if I'm
wrong but the allotment Act was forced
on your people so they had to before it
was communally owned the land they
shared and then they were forced to
individually start owning it yes that's
right it was forced and you know today
we still have aspects of communal
culture like our iwanchka dances which
Go the whole month of June we have these
Community dinners and anyone can come
and be fed but people who are
traditional Cooks could often throughout
the year be play be paid in blankets and
they may not have the money or the gas
money to get to the communal cooking uh
in order to feed all the people so you
can see how there's a lot of tension
around the communal even the society we
live in is so set up to make it really
difficult to even practice our communal
ways which are still going but under
complex tensions
and you've written this book and I
really recommend it it's called a calm
and normal heart and in this book
Chelsea introduces words from the
version language and through these words
that you learn as you read the book you
get to know concepts of your culture did
you learn about some cultural concepts
by
um
you started learning the language right
you didn't grow up with it no did you
learn uh some cultural values as well as
you
yes so you may hear like the term remade
creation tonight and we'll talk about it
a little bit and what it means but the
it's another way of saying it one way of
saying it is reconnection Which is
popular for native people today because
in 1956 the Native American relocation
act took a lot of people away from their
reservations into cities but even before
that for osages when we had this oil
money and there the reign of terror like
Osage murders for oil money was going on
quite a many number of osages moved to
California because they were fleeing
those murders and they had the resources
to do it
so uh for me I grew up in Virginia and
my paternal grandmother my eco had gone
to boarding school and the result of any
native person today has a grandparent
who went to boarding school like and the
one of the results of that is language
loss and so no Osage people today
um speak Osage language we're
revitalizing it it's a dormant language
and I was impacted to learn it in 2016
when I was 2017 when I received this
Challenge from poets and Chiapas and
Oaxaca in Mexico and they gave a
challenge to United States native
writers why aren't you writing in your
languages so I I thought that was absurd
because it's an oral language and no one
speaks it but I just started looking
into it and our tribe was making efforts
to revitalize it and had released an app
so I was I had been going through these
intense mental health crises in my 20s
and when I started to learn the language
and reconnect to My Tribe I stabilized
like totally and um so those those
Concepts that are in the language one of
them I can note is
um you know in English we have like this
object-oriented sense a lot of things
are objects or function as objects and
subjects but
uh it's not it's not like that there's a
lot more intimacy like uh and
relationships to everything especially
uh plants and land so that's another tie
into ownership is there's this idea of
ancestral land and like that our land is
kind of uh living and it's part of our
bodies
so that's a concept from the language is
that also why there was a communal
ownership of the land uh instead of this
individual chopping it up into pieces I
can imagine if you see the Earth as a
living thing you might not be so
inclined to chop it up
or am I just trying to decide no as I I
mean I'm not an expert in you know like
world people groups over time
um but as I understand it you know more
anciently you know everyone here you
know your your bodies are sort of coming
from an ancestral land base when you
look at your four grandparents and where
they may have their ancestors may have
lived you know hundreds and hundreds of
years ago and and so when you're living
uh in in
where there's a indigenous plants to
that continent continent and then you
yourself are indigenous to that
continent there's a kinship in a
relationship and um you know you just
travel for your needs and you take care
of each other because you all share an
initiative and an objective and that is
to carry on your ways and protect your
plants and
um sort of take care of one another and
so I think the reason that land is more
divided like that one reason that it
might be is because as people in the
United States we don't necessarily share
these objectives or these ways we're
fragmented isolated and disassociated
from one another so there's no basis for
an inherent ability to take care of and
care for one another because we don't
necessarily share a common interest
that's a really good answer and I think
they will link with our guests tonight
who are here on the screen
um first is akitami I will say a little
China cup
is this okay
are we good
all right well done
um akitami is uh she's a Zhang me woman
from the kiratima First Peoples of the
Himalaya she's also an artist she grew
up in the tea plantations of Darjeeling
and she moved she traveled to Mainland
India when she was 15 without any
resources or connections
and she started working as an artist
since then she has founded the sister
Library which is the first feminist
Library of India this is a communal
place where people can get together and
read texts by women also women from
traditionally oppressed costs and tribes
as her tribe traditionally has also been
oppressed she's also started that AFI
art room datafi is known maybe you know
it from the movie Slumdog Millionaire
it's known as the biggest uh slum area
in Mumbai and in the middle ackia
started an art room where locals get
together and make art she has also
started a fellowship for girls to get a
higher education
she sets up resources for instance
during the covert lockdown she started a
food program or when there's floods
alongside this she somehow also has a
flourishing art practice
and she's very young
Margaret Levy she's a
political scientist a professor
you may have seen her before here at the
interval and I got to know her through
her thinking and writing on the concept
of a Community of Faith
f-a-t-e not face face
which is based on the concept that we
all have a community of people that we
believe our faith is linked with that's
our Community of Faith and Margaret's
one of her concerns that she addresses
is that people see their community of
Fate as a very small group and they
Define the others as threatening and
denying all our complex Mutual in the
interdependencies in the process
Brian Eno he is well known as a musician
and an artist as well as a writer and
speaker
um he is the co-founder of the long now
uh he as he's a long-term thinker and
um therefore I think it makes sense that
he's in the ecological movement he
founded a charity called Earth percent I
encourage you to look it up it's in my
own words it's a way to pay your tax to
the Earth so it allows for artists to
share a percentage of their income with
the Earth and this money goes to groups
that protect the planet or help restore
the planet
I've had a lot of conversations with
Brian about
um the role art can play in examining
society's feelings and redefining new
values and a lot of what I say
originated in those conversations and
I've asked them the question that I've
asked Chelsea
I'm very involved right now in a project
that's actually thinking about
reimagining property rights it involves
an academic perspective which comes from
me and my team and two organizations a
dark matter and radical exchange which
are actually engaged in in on the ground
work of Designing new ways of property
rights and property writing as dark
matter calls it our goals here are to
transform the kind of mindset that we
have that was built at least in the West
in the 18th century and undermining in
many ways emphasizing private property
and therefore undermining all kinds of
common property and shared property
so our goal is to think about what
property can do for people and property
rights can do for people in terms of
economic well-being in terms of politics
and political equality and in terms of
protecting the environment the Earth and
indigenous cultures and then designing
institutions that will achieve those
ends and that are alternatives to the
current framework that we have
I think to approach the word property I
think of it from a very decolonial
standpoint because of my identity as an
indigenous person and how my community
the tummies did not really have a
concept of
property as it is experienced and is
conceptualized in the world today
property in the sense of owning land and
owning a house and we did not have that
so we had like Community owned spaces
that were not permanent it was always
shifting them talking about like
thousands of years back when we lived as
free people that are not colonized there
never was this concept of really owning
property really owning land everything
was there for everyone
to community share and be a part of and
that is how I think of property as well
now like thankfully because of this
practice that my ancestors had I think
it's from memory in my genes or
something I always love the spaces that
are more Collective
spaces where we did not have like a
single authoritative figure would be the
owner and the rule maker and then
everyone would have to adhere to that
and generate wealth
for the owner of the property and maybe
that is why I never really
had a job I became an artist and uh
started creating spaces that could be
owned by everyone where people could
think of ownership and property
differently and an example of that could
be sister Library where people
who come to the library I tell them that
the library is as much theirs as it's
mine because the books have been mine
but it's an open space which is
community run everyone is welcome to
participate and think together to lead
this space in different directions
I think what's really needed now is a
discussion about what
should be a common ownership
what should be regarded as unownable by
any individual and what can be allowed
to be private
I think artworks being relatively
unimportant parts of the world
in some respects can be privatized can
can be private
I think Water Supplies
Land Air
certain medical types of intervention
shouldn't be private I think they should
be publicly earned
they should be a Commons in fact
so of course it's easy for somebody like
me to say they should be a Commons but
the question will immediately come so
who maintains the commons and who pays
for the commons
this is a complicated question and I
don't know if this is the place to try
to answer that
it's it's a question I've been thinking
about a lot because
certain aspects of my life that are
currently private I've tried to make
into a comments this studio for example
um more and more I use it as a place
where people meet to have conversations
so it's become a sort of it's become
common property of a lot of people
though of course my name is still on the
Deeds and I still pay the rates but I've
tried to deal with this issue of what
should be privately ownable
and by saying that actually I'm not sure
the property of this kind should be
privately owned so I'm trying to work
out a kind of compromise which I think
is a type of compromise that a lot of
people will have to be thinking about in
the future as the notion of unlimited
private property becomes more and more
difficult to sustain
so you know there are lots of people who
own things
and perhaps like me they they question
whether they ought to own them outright
and maybe there is room for some sort of
future where
we make kind of co-ownership agreements
with the rest of the world
giving is is actually a bigger pleasure
than getting
and I think on one of the social
Transformations we might see soon is the
understanding of that that
to reverse that the sort of capitalist
model where pleasure comes from getting
and say no actually pleasure comes from
giving
pleasure comes from sharing
[Applause]
one thing that these speakers agree on
is that
um sharing seems increasingly urgent and
sharing of a reaching rethinking
property rights seems unnecessary
it brings up this question of
responsibility
there's also the question of how we got
to the place
where we are now that we own things so
I'm Dutch
my country has been very active in the
past in stealing slave trading do I have
more because of what my country did and
how is that for a starting point to
start saying and now I would like to
share
um and it brings up a question it's not
one of the three questions or questions
that I wanted to ask you Chelsea um when
I got to know you and reading your work
I started looking up
um
always land it was originally they were
on and I looked up the land that we are
now originally on and I'm from
Netherlands you probably already know
this uh Rama tush olona peoples but not
on this land
um
I see a lot of people making a
declaration at the beginning of a
fencing I want to acknowledge and I felt
strange about it because I thought
if I would steal Fred shoes and then I
would say I just want to acknowledge
that these shoes are friends
it's
if you don't connect that to any kind of
action
but how do you feel about these
acknowledgments and would you like to
acknowledge something about where we are
now
sorry is this a hard question no I I I
think I'm just laughing with everyone
else it's great and I appreciate the
question yeah so the the ohlonema alone
people are here today uh they have an
Ohlone Cafe where they share uh some of
their traditions and they have a
language and a culture and they're very
um
alive and present and they
um the sagorate land trust uh yeah
has has become a land Collective that is
indigenously run and that's here in San
Francisco and they're working to kind of
the way I would this is my personal
opinion I'm not speaking for anyone but
myself but I I feel that Native American
people are not necessarily functioning
indigenously across all nations in the
United States and that for myself you
know to function indigenously I think
you are operating as a land protector
and you're also working with some of
your plants and so they are doing that
they're restoring that uh and it's
native women-led and so if you want to
you know think about like taking the
action towards these shoes these Ohlone
mocks moxins
um you know you could look for ways to
support the sagorate Land Trust
thank you Elvis Dyson with the second
question that we have how can we fix
fast injustices around property or uh
improve future ways of sharing and you
shared a video with us has to do with
injustices and sharing I'll just play it
first
it's by artist Nathan young they want to
say something before we play it oh well
just a moment ago when you were talking
about
um how land ownership Works in Amsterdam
um and how did we come to this place of
land being divided I I just thought it
was an interesting reflection to share
that
um as I understand it in the United
States when
the in order for someone to become a
Statesman during the colonial period you
had to be a landowner and you had to be
married and these were symbols of uh
your ability to Steward land so it was a
kind of a moral world view estimate
estimation of a person as a good person
or not that could you be uh like have uh
Purity kind of so it's Christian values
that the foundation of the United States
is created on and those come from this
idea of land ownership and and as I
understand it as well you know that was
used and politicized by the Roman Empire
to help spread Empire and so I think
that's why
um anyway
so this video will be by Nathan young
who is Lenape and that's the land from
the from New York area Manhattan and
he's a great Tulsa artist fellow and a
friend and he has this video with plin's
Indian sign language which was a shared
way of talking sort of a common tongue
for peoples across native people who had
come into contact with each other so
yeah
I have to say I haven't
sorry this is my bed it's in the wrong
order
I'm gonna just
go to
the video
here we go
thank you
so
yeah in this video uh which is we were
able to get it from Oklahoma
contemporary show uh and so just
acknowledging them I think like we see
this
problem with sharing and if you want to
say okay let's share right
let's really go into how can you do that
how can you make it work and sharing
knowledge sharing Resources with people
with whom there's a power imbalance or a
values difference uh clearly has has
consequences and we know that from the
history of our nation and so I I think
that with Native people today
you know native people have our own
stories and histories that we don't
necessarily share and not necessarily
willing to share knowledge or share
anything with people who we would deem
as as Outsiders or settlers or
non-natives and so in order to
investigate how can you share I think
you have to look at at the value system
underlying the sharing and like what
kind of world view and ethics and Faith
Community the the sharing is coming from
and so
um
yeah maybe I'll stop there it's so
you're what you're touching on is this
idea that you can share but before you
share if you established you have to
establish trust so a mutual trust I
guess yeah what ways can trust be
established you said if you recognize
that you have shared values right
because in in uh Turtle Island like on
this continent when we're encountering
you know uh Church whites right we're
just seeing them as oh it's a people who
we don't know and they're hungry and uh
as Brian you know was saying you know
sharing is the real gift like in in
Osage culture you know generosity is one
of our important most important highest
values that when you show generosity
towards someone you're taking care of
them and that it creates a relationship
that you know they would take care of
you too and there's the a kinship of
just being a person and so that that
comes from the idea that no people are
are really bad you know people aren't
bad under sinful but in in Christianity
the concept of forgiveness is very
strong and so you could be forgiven for
a sin if it was for God's will right but
in in we don't have a word for I'm sorry
and so if you there's there's more of an
emphasis on having good ways and doing
things that
um just are respectful and so I think we
have to like acknowledge some of the
complications within like our Different
World Views and I think that it's fine
you know to have any religion that you
want but it's really important to
respect the radical Dignity of every
person even if they don't believe the
same as you
I think another way that
um we establish trust it's not really
trust but by contracts by saying you'll
be punished if you don't do it the way
we create a bond so I guess that's why
we do it in business yeah
um yeah writing it down right contracts
and law as you as you address so well in
your book and yeah I mean I guess that's
one more thing I would note is that when
it comes to establishing the trust like
why native people would just
automatically help these people these
Fiji poor pitiful and these humble
people that we don't know is that
um like
when the Black robes or the Jesuits came
and they told us their story of of Jesus
we we had it in our old tradition that
they gave us a stack of leaves with a
new moral code on it so we were thankful
for that because we had now a new uh
code which adds an enrichment or or a
new just more more abundance of
understanding and we also then told them
our our stories because it was
understood that when someone tells you
their stories you believe them and you
respect it and it's holy and it's sacred
and there wasn't that reciprocity within
Christianity and the way Christianity
became tied to land owning it was one
one story is the only one and and one
way is the only one and so I think if we
can look at like the foundational laws
of our country and of some of these
contracts and where the ideas come from
that can help us like recreate a sense
of actually all people are all nations
are equal and all people are equally
dignified and it's not like some people
are basically Savages and that that
those Concepts and those language are
still in our laws and they're still
alive and they still operate within our
minds even if we don't fully
um aren't fully aware of it
oh let's watch what the the people on
the screen have said and reply to this
question on past and justices and future
ways of sharing
the answers and the question like
individuals and communities
sorry
yeah oh right some people were on it
they were already looking at me like
they were worrying about you yeah
I have to say I haven't thought very
much about the first part of that
question past injustices and that's
partly because I suppose I see the
present injustices
so clearly as a continuation of those
anyway so I've been thinking about how
do we change things
in the present tense
and of course one of the most important
of those is huge wealth inequality which
has increased dramatically in the last
20 or 30 years generally there's a Chasm
opening between the very rich and
everybody else
so it seems to me completely sensible
to have progressive taxation
aimed specifically at taming that type
that inequality
and I also think having caps on welds is
a very worthwhile idea that's that's one
that's the sort of financial version of
inequality the other thing I think is
important is to
try to see who we actually value in
society
and to Perhaps Perhaps ask ourselves the
question of why is it that the people we
value most
usually get paid least
so I think we have to fix past
injustices we see particularly with land
and buildings but also other
corporations as well I shouldn't say
particularly land and buildings that
there has been an inequitable from my
perspective certainly an unequal by all
perspective distribution of the income
and even the capacity to control what
those buildings provide and do or what
those corporations do so we have if we
turn to firms let's start there there
have been Arguments for a very long time
about polluting firms about what to do
when a firm that is say co-producing
even apart from the fossil fuel question
but when it's actually polluting the air
around it and who who pays to fix that
up or who pays for the health costs of
those who are both working in that plant
as well as those who are affected by
those black plants those are past
injustices which over time the laws have
evolved in part large part because of
public pressure often Union pressure
sometimes just interest group lobbies
and mobilized citizens to fix those
clear injustices that emerge from the
property rights when we look at big
buildings today particularly those which
have traditionally been offices and
which a lot of workers aren't returning
to there's lots of empty commercial
office space any big city almost
anywhere in the world right now is
suffering and some more than others just
suffering from a serious homelessness
problem or a lack of sufficient
residents why can't we transform some of
those spaces into residences well we
can't because of the nature of the
property rights and who has priority
there in determining how those things
should be used and what kind of income
should be flowing from it that's an
injustice we need to change if we are
actually going to make some distance on
providing housing for all those who need
it given that we and not building so
much more housing and creating all kinds
of environmental problems with the drain
on water and and resources and land that
we already have in our Urban spaces and
then the final big Injustice of course
is the Injustice that comes from the way
in which the property rights system has
worked certain actors get a
disproportionate share of the revenue
it's not surprising right now that we're
seeing unionization begin to arise again
at least in the United States where it
had clearly declined so those are some
of the kinds of injustices that flow
from property rights and again can be
corrected by action and By changes in
laws
it's important to understand
how different societies also experience
property and how it is linked with power
and relationship and social hierarchy
although it may not be true for all the
societies but like so for some societies
like the caste Society in India and in
in other South Asian countries there is
relationship between property ownership
and cost status as well which I think
has to be dismantled you know as a child
I never thought I was a servant even if
I grew up in a house where everyone was
in the plantation slavery I never
thought I was just instigiously because
I did not understand that and my parents
never told me that that is what I was
destined to be it was only when I left
the house
I was told continuously that there's no
point even my school has told there is
no point studying because some people
are just meant to serve others there is
that very racist notion or like of
people who have been historically
disenfranchised to be just again like
just people who are supposed to be poor
and people who do not have that space at
all and for that like when we talk about
property and when we talk about sharing
I think these forms of injustices are
the ones that are still practiced and
practiced by people who are just like
everyday people you know people who
teach in universities to people who are
like working as kuriksha drivers it's
like across class who still hold these
views and it's because
these are like these are Notions that
are
three modern forms of governance it's
like
pre-democratic system which is
pre-capitalism even it goes beyond it
goes beyond thousands of years and so
we'll have to start with radical change
there and for people to understand that
everybody is capable of of experiencing
ownership and property and I think after
we come to a space where there is that
understanding we can start thinking of
how property can be experienced
differently and not just through this
very model of inheritance and like this
very patriarchal lineage system
interesting to me that well Brian and
Margaret are really practical they need
to get on with this
and do these things and they're very
sensible areas where our attention
should be and then there you and Aki
emphasize before we do this we need to
establish Trust
see each other acknowledge each other
value each other and um restore some
yeah
problems yeah I think that the first two
had a an emphasis on systemic and policy
changes which can do so much but in
order to affect such a humongous change
as to create big more sharing and and
radical Equity I think it can't be
accomplished in one generation I think
it would take seven generations that's
usually the amount of time that like
native people plan like a like a I guess
like a cycle for and so I think that it
begins with the individual and everybody
that I really believe in making
reparations and reparative work and you
can simply look at your ancestry and
people get so like freaked out like it's
such a big deal like let oh my
grandfather my great-grandmother did
this but everybody has like a lot of
different ancestors and some of your
ancestors even from your four grand
parents you have the grandparents that
you liked and were great and some of
them you know needed some support to act
better in their life and if you um I
really think that you can simply look at
your family and some of the things that
your family your grandparents your great
grandparents your great great
grandparents and so on and so forth you
can simply just look at some of the
things that they did in their life that
you're proud of and you think had a good
effect and were good for you and good
for other people as well as things they
did which although they benefited you
were userious and need reparative work
and you can simply make reparations by
noting the communities that they may
have disenfranchised and working to
support those communities
um through any reparative work doesn't
just mean paying reparations I do think
that's important but the land back
movement as well I think you can
actually give land back to native
nations you can actually do reparative
work and it's not that crazy
um I also think that you shouldn't only
be focusing on yourself as this like
power holder and writer of past wrongs
you also need to look at your
disinheritance of what colonization and
Christian spread of Empire may have
removed from you anciently and you know
sometimes people get this idea of like
oh I don't I did go back to Ireland and
I bought a kill but really there was
nothing in that and it's not about
necessarily going into like the the
colonial structures that exist today I
think it's something simple that you can
do is look up a continent that you know
your body is kind of coming from
According to the framework I'm
presenting maybe you think differently
about science that's fine but
a continent that you know you have a
deep protective spiritual tie to
hundreds and thousands of years ago and
look up a plant that grows indigenously
on that continent just a plant that
grows across the whole continent instead
of burning sage
um in your apartment burn that plant and
pray with it and think about your
reparative work with it and do your
10-minute calm meditation with that
plant instead of the you know the
commercialized smudging white Shaman at
something
and then also the other thing you can do
is look at the issues that are affecting
that land now in terms of resource
extraction on that continent and just
research it and learn more about it and
you know I'm not saying you need to go
re-indigenize yourself to a content and
leave the United States that's not what
I'm saying I'm saying that you can have
more resources by getting rid of some of
that guilt by doing reparative work
looking at the issues taking action
praying with the plants because that's a
resource that you deserve to have
inherited that you have been cut off
from and it's a horrible thing and you
need to be re-strengthened
that you said that really well I've you
said before that the question of work
and individuals and communities do you
have spent some time thinking about it
and it was hard to answer and here you
go like this is what you can do
let's look at what
um Brian Margaret and Aki said about it
and now
I'm just hoping
that it's
there
there it is
the answers and the question like
individuals and communities can do like
you know you have to start doing and
doing without expectation I think it is
something that I have also learned
through practice I was always taught to
expect a certain return after you do the
work but that's not how things work you
just do you just give you just share
without expecting there's going to be
this return so like when we are doing
the scholarship for the girls like the
working with savitri my fellowship or
like supporting the women in dharavi
during the covet crisis
or just putting together resources when
there are floods and or even doing the
library I think this idea that this is
going to be the input and this is going
to be the output of it it's also sort of
very capitalist
exchange and we I try to step out of
that and just do and it's also this is
the reason why we are not funded by a
huge corporation or any Grant because
this is what the grants ask as well like
you know you put this and then it has to
be a result and then there has to be a
multiplication of that result and you
have to scale up that's not how I
function at all you just do and then it
may turn into something that is positive
and hit me turn into something that is
great but it may not also but that
should not stop us from doing and I
think everybody is capable of doing like
everybody is capable of giving back
here I'm going to come right back to
politics I really think political
Solutions are needed and that involves
ensuring political equality one so
getting making sure that everybody who
wants to vote can vote that they're as
informed as they can possibly be that
they have the political capacity to
exercise voice in appropriate ways but
it's incredibly important to build
democracies that one not only listen to
those various voices and take them on
and help to resolve conflicts in the
ways that we've been talking about
but also by creating that kind of
democracy and reduce and creating
political equality within democracy we
reduce the power of the super powerful
and increase the power of the less
powerful and of the of the majority
really uh the multiple voices that need
to be heard and that I think is crucial
for achieving economic equality because
what's standing in our way here what's
standing in our way is a series of
government rules that in we're back to
property rights here that enable certain
people to disproportionately benefit
from the kinds of property rights
structure that we have and if we're
going to change the rules of the game
we're going to change the legislation
that requires immense political pressure
and it has to be a relatively even
playing field and it is not right now so
what do I think people should do they
need to vote but they need to mobilize
others to vote they need to fight they
need to fight for the issues they care
about in a way that is civil and takes
into account the interests of others
and they have to be able to exert
political pressure in a collective way
on their legislative legislators so that
some change can actually be brought
about
the first
realization we have to have is that
there are no externalities
if you are producing things and using
resources and and dumping uh the wastes
from those
you have to take responsibility for for
every effect of of what you're doing in
as far as those things can be measured
and discerned
that actually straight away is a huge
inequality reducer the second thing I'd
say is as Margaret Levy said
unionization
that is so important I think it really
makes a difference if workers have a
voice and their voice is recognized and
respected
third thing I talk about is reform of
politics itself
we're stuck with political models that
really date from the 19th century
and yet there are new ones emerging
which are much much more interesting and
exciting and liberating
and those are things like citizens
assemblies
particularly the kinds of citizens
assemblies that have
participants chosen by Lottery
um or saltation as it's known the last
thing I would say we could do
and this might seem like a
quite weirdly uh
authoritarian stance to take is that I
think social media have to be reformed
quite radically at the moment we're
living with social media whose
algorithms are specifically designed to
create
polarization
discontent argument
and distraction
and we more than ever we need citizens
to be engaged
at the level of policy decisions this is
why that first suggestion of um citizens
assemblies is important
but we need them to be informed there's
no point having citizens engaged in
things if they're completely befuddled
by the kind of rubbish that Fox News is
putting out
so we really need to start thinking
knowledge understanding of the situation
that we're in at present is at an
absolute premium
a lot of potential areas where we could
take action what's there one thing that
was mentioned that is significant to you
stands out where you think
I'm thinking about what Brian said about
social media I really agree with that
but
um in terms of taking action like
we haven't pointed it out yet but it's
probably obvious to everyone that you
know the way Christianity influenced
capitalism and United States law and the
way those things influenced ownership
and the way that influences sharing
all influences also uh the environment
and land and global warming and the way
that uh the the weather is changing and
the land is changing and to to give an
example of how he said like if you take
responsibility or you even even if you
can't take responsibility personally for
um
resource abuse if you can stand up or
Ally with or protect land that is very
impactful because you create a community
there of a shared initiative which
allows that sharing kind of uh
parameters to exist and then on top of
that
um you are working with I guess
decolonizing decolonizing
um how we interact with our environment
just through protecting land to give an
example in Tulsa right now
they're looking at building uh like a
third Dam near the South part of Tulsa
and part of the reason that people can't
kind of take action against the dam is
because there's a narrative that and a
uh like a teaching and an understanding
of of a river
and this idea of what a river should
look like it should have sort of like a
European aesthetic because it's still in
some ways a colony here in the U.S and
so the the Arkansas River is actually a
braided Prairie stream it's not supposed
to look like a high water river it's
supposed to look like sand banks with
streams of water weaving through and so
when people look at the river and they
say oh how ugly wouldn't it be nice if
it looked beautiful like a river so why
not build another Dam because it fits
into like my aesthetic that I'm bringing
as like a colonial inheritance and so if
you can just that's an example like just
by protecting if you can stand up for
the dam you build this sense of
community you can protect the land and
just the the pushback against that kind
of one percent thing that you achieve
through that results and people feeling
more like uh there's a sense of
community I should show up to vote
because people are working to protect
each other so I don't know if I outlined
that really well but I think that when
you go into one area of this you go into
all the areas of it and it has this
ripple effect between land people wealth
property
and and it also dies in with what both
Margaret and Brian pointed out uh the
importance of being informed and getting
your information yeah if you think that
River you want the river to look nicer
yeah you know but if you're informed you
can make a better judgment and so these
are all huge things that have been
suggested
um we've been asking what kind of things
can we do what kind of parties can we
embark on
um some things are uh individual so can
we make a personal commitment start can
we start looking at our ancestors where
we came from what that means can we
make a commitment to take responsibility
or try to make a commitment if we have
room in our lives to be responsible for
all the externalities that are
that are caused by our existence could
it be communal should be local or Global
should be your art project the
storytelling project or should it be
political like Margaret is saying who
should the target audience be of a
project like this could it be children
or politicians there's a lot of
questions and I think what
ensures that we need to do things and we
need to get out of paralysis if we're in
paralysis and what will motivate us to
do things
uh I think it's our feelings hmm
um I think the things we talked about
today
um
how we feel about each other
who we trust the feelings that we have
about sharing that might be changing the
feelings about how do we value in
society a big motivator for people is
how can I be happier you said you became
happier when you connected
uh to your ancestral lands and your
values so
this is where you come in that's a
really hard part
we would really like your personal take
on this you all have this piece of paper
let's see
with a question what can individuals and
communities do in order to change the
trajectory of increasing inequality in
the long term please read your thoughts
on it maybe the products that you're
involved in your experiences questions
things that were said tonight that you
really agreed with or disagreed with and
there will be a place to leave them
before you go
and your nose there it is it's on the
corner of the bar
um
we will take
your thoughts as a first step for the
workshop at the internet archive on
Friday you're all invited to come
everybody who has an idea they want to
share a question or a thought on Friday
they can give a lightning speech as
Brian Eno's invention a two-minute
speech where you
share what it is that you want to share
and then we will continue that
conversation Friday at 4 30 together at
the internet archive
now we will have some time for you to
write down whatever you want to write
down and to ask questions maybe you want
to ask Chelsea questions
um about the things she's been talking
about or about her beautiful book which
is also here for sale
with such an ingrained cultural historic
architectural
and Community set of biases that we have
inherited that have led us to the
position where we have given over so
much control of our planet to so few
people
what fundamental change needs to happen
in our thinking that has allowed us to
give it all away so that we can find a
way to take it back
you talked about values talked about
feelings what is that thing that has
allowed us as a civilization as a people
as a society to give 99.9 to 0.1 percent
and be happy concept yeah thank you for
the for the insightful question I think
it's the concept that land is an object
and that our bodies are not land
our bodies
our land we walk on the land we are
animals with the other animals we're
part of we are the land and the land is
a person the land is animate
thank you for your
well-formulated and really good question
and important question I think
um
my take on this is it's tied to what I
found out as I got out of debt uh if
you're in debt there's nothing you can
do like you're in just constantly
stressed
um you can't expect much from people who
are in that situation once you get more
room to think and to feel and you're
able to do things you realize how much
of your humanity is actually stolen by
the systems that we're living in so
if I walk past that person who is passed
out I don't want to
but I cannot get involved I've done it
in my life and it doesn't turn out well
because I don't have the skills to fix
problems that huge
um but that is taking something from me
uh it's a it allows it it doesn't allow
me to be the person who I want to be
and I think when we start recognizing
that the fact that we have no choice to
buy but buying tomatoes that were
um
harvested by people who are underpaid
that we have no choice to join a bank
but to join a bank who is involved in
land grabbing in Africa
that is changing who we are it's
changing our personality we have to mute
parts of ourselves
um I believe
and that's my experience that we don't
want to mute and I think as Chelsea
described that she became happier when
she returned uh to her more communal
living and found these values that she
was in line with I think when you're
able to live more in line with your
values you become a lot happier and
I think I've seen so much commercials on
TV in the U.S since I got here and about
half of them are do you want to get
happier
so maybe that's the way in you know do
you want to get happier
yeah I mean everyone can if you want to
expand the concept Beyond like that
that's what I think the change that
needs to happen is but as to how you get
toward that and how you integrate that
understanding into every aspect of life
the like curriculum set for it is
renatriation and everyone can
participate in rematriation it's
indigenous and black women-led I believe
some people think it's just indigenous
women-led but I think that black
indigenous people need to work together
to help lead reparative work in the
United States but I think that um yeah
like you're just first of all it's kind
of a simple process but it it goes
beyond self-care
because self-care
you can still get in trouble and get
attacked for appropriation and someone's
going to tell you go get your own
culture and so that's where
um rematriation came in was it's a form
of self-care that is anti-appropriative
and anti-racist
foundationally and by Nature so
rematriation means reparative work for
your ancestors as well as learning what
you've been disinherited of reconnecting
to
um the things that you've lost you can
do that through land and I focus on land
like to give you like a a broader brief
overview of people who speak about these
ideas and examples you have um N Scott
Mama day
um Robin wall kimmerer and Natalie Diaz
and they each have a different kind of
recommendation for you of how you do
this Robin wall kimmerer will her
rhetoric is as I understand it's kind of
you can indigenize yourself to the land
where you live now by learning the
beliefs of tribes by whom you live and
kind of allying with them if you can't
ever get them to even speak to you
I added that last part I noticed and
then and Scott Mama day is saying kind
of like okay I want to acknowledge that
Cowboys and Ranchers have also lived on
the land and they know the land and
everyone has achieved some type of
belonging in the United States through
their tenure here and so go beyond your
tenure and begin to uh keep the Earth
and he he talks about that through a
story of like the Grasshopper And that's
in the book earthkeeper so it's kind of
I think I would translate it as to like
basically if you spend time with land
this is an idea that Dr Phil Cash Cash
uh who's Nene Pooh will say in the land
will will speak to you it will you'll
get you'll get ideas through
meditatively sitting with land and put
it that way in like the sort of English
thought World thought world view and
then Natalie Diaz will have none of
either of those things and she says no
you need to go back to your ancestral
Waters and immerse your body in them
because they're are certain things you
can't understand when you are
disconnected from Land you come from
Land you come from people and we when we
come we become so disconnected from that
we can't understand
um how to really be healthy and you know
I think Christianity and other it
becomes Like A coping mechanism that's
you know maybe better than like
alcoholism but I don't know that it's
able to reverse the path it doesn't have
necessarily
in and of itself solely
the tools to reverse where we are in
terms of our species taking care of each
other and being able to continue
surviving
I'm so glad that you added this part
about if you can get them to talk to you
just for all the people who were
banned or you know exiled or right
restraining order you can't go back you
know not even allowed to go back into
their countries
um I'm curious so you had a really good
question people have really good
questions sometimes also have very good
answer so do you also have your own
answer
um
oh boy um don't quote me about this but
I think we have to undo the
value that we give to the accumulation
of things and reinstate the value of the
accumulation of people
that's tough
yep that would be hard because we have
all grown up generation after generation
believing that things are more important
than people
thank you
for had time for the evening
um but this conversation will continue
tonight feel free to hang out and stick
around for a second and we'll also
continue at the internet archive
at 4 30 right
yes 430 internet archive if you you can
sign up there's a list where you can
sign up you can also send an email and
then we'll let you know how you can get
in and it will be informal and hopefully
fun yeah if you've never been which I
bet a lot of you actually have but if
you've never been it's a really amazing
building and they have an entire um
backup of the internet there it's like
kind of a like digital religious
experiences
um
um it is uh
fun yeah Funston and Clement I think
right yeah that sounds right it's like
the the church looking building there
um but we'll we'll send more details to
everyone
um but give it up
for Bethany and Chelsea
[Applause]
thank you so much for coming out and I
just have like one or two last um
housekeepings we're gonna clear the
chairs here
um but please grab your drink so that no
one accidentally
um you know breaks the glass
um and
um feel free to enjoy thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign